[Music]
the Golgi apparatus the most amazing
thing about this is Alex true love is
going to have sex next week huh hot
sweaty intercourse of a sexual kind
Oh my name is Alex true love yes that's
my real name I have a 4.0 GPA I'm
student body president and I have a
great girlfriend you're coming with us
to this party and you're gonna let your
little constipated hair down and enjoy
yourself one join the cool kids
I think we're here to corrupt you Alex
[Music]
so I have a girlfriend
I know oh she's adorable Cheers this is
guy who I'm pretty sure has a crush on
me and I guess I'm not repulsed by the
idea look it's a confusing time man
everywhere you look someone is onion
sexual or transitioning how did you like
know you're a gay penny no you stay
what's going on you trying to do virgin
eyes you for the past eight months you
won't let me
it's like Mad Max out here guys doing
guys girls doing girls girls turning
into guys and doing girls that used to
do girls in guys ah
I'm over at Dell this whole thing sex
love an out to someone these explain
modern high school boys to me
are you so scared of
love is strange
[Music]
[Music]